well you did Fargo it did they do Fargo
because I mean it said that is one of
the greatest TV series they've done in
quite some time
Fargo the movie or the TV show TV show
I'm the only actor who's been in both
were you in the movie
hell you told us in the movie when the
guys putting a leg in the chipper yeah
end of the movie the other guys watching
a shitty soap opera uh-huh and I'm in
the shitty soap opera in HD do they film
the soap opera for that no the Coen
brothers the producer of the Coen
brothers was an old high school buddy of
mine he knew that I had done a really
bad soap opera years before and he goes
it's great let's just get the footage
just get get the rights to it cost like
a dollar so that's what they did they
got they was something we had filmed
years before and then did the people who
did the TV show did they have any idea
that that connection existed liquids no
no so that was just a happy coincidence
except for the same producer John
Cameron so he he then brought me in to
do Ronald Reagan right right TV you did
use you sat down and you said whale you
did a little rink where you go again you
know once you once you look my kids grew
up in the Reagan era all the 80s you
couldn't get the guy off TV yeah there
you go he was the scolder in chief you
just see you do Reagan I do Clinton we
ask that awesome now what's your Clinton
let's hear a little bit of you're
actually an excerpt from his
autobiography she ate I met him once I
met him in Miami how was he when you
meet him hilarious he is right oh it was
a function for Haiti some some relief
finally I saw you I've chased women
through the woods like that no we got
the guy who was his assistant told us me
and the star of Burn Notice he goes if
you guys get near the end of the line
he'll have more time if you get near the
front of the line he's got to blow past
you like good advice yeah got way near
the end we're 20 feet away he looks over
as he goes oh man
hey I love your show
and we literally both of us we look
behind us maybe Dennis HOF from the so
we find we trying to get up there and he
says the words he goes Burn Notice is my
favorite show you play my favorite
character he's saying this to me Sam
we're both over the hill warriors I'm
like what Oh Billy I was watching burn
know yeah because he goes Hilary's gone
all week this is when she was Secretary
of State so I'm home I watch the show oh
it's good to where's the girl he did end
it with that where's the girl that's
gonna be pretty great that's hilarious
ed he did it when when Hilary had
pneumonia bill was like well I watch a
lot of TV I saw a TV that she had
pneumonia I guess he's just watching all
his program and I watch the shoulder
it's my favorite Kirk know he needs that
was his cover show because he has too
much blame what he does when she's gone
it's the one show that you could pick it
would make sense it's like Law & Order
can you say something is Reagan well
there you go again and well they are
barbarians we start bombing in five
minutes
Nancy there we go
I had my salad tossed by Cicely Tyson